le bac c'est dans un mois pour les
élèves c'est donc la période des
révisions et ils ont à leur disposition
de nouveaux outils notamment des sites
internet
le dernier-né d'entre eux s'appelle be
back en fait c'est un site communautaire
sur lequel chaque élève peut donner ses
trucs ses ficelles pour retenir un cours
avec en plus de la vidéo des documents
radio et pour plus de sécurité
tous les articles sont corrigés par des
étudiants mallory ao nous claire-marie
doni en ce moment il prépare son nouvel
album
mais aujourd'hui abdel malik donne de
son temps pour un enregistrement un peu
différent mais il n'est certain
n'existait dans la mesure où ils pensent
je suis fatigué moore sur la pensée de
descartes une contribution pour be back
point com un site de révision
participatif pour le rappeur slameur qui
décroche à 1,17 au bac de philo il
s'agit de donner l'exemple des fois on
peut être isolé et c est le fait d'avoir
accès justement à un ordinateur
travailler avec d'autres c'est quelque
chose qui est je dirais qui est motivant
un outil comme ça moi peut-être gamin si
j'avais eu ça aurait été encore mieux
c'est partage de savoirs pour un outil
de révision entièrement gratuit
à moins d'un mois de l'examen c'est ce
qui a séduit ces deux lycéens déçu par
certains sites
pratiquement tous été payant ou demander
une cotisation par appel par carte bleue
on commence exercice et quand on tourne
la page mais un peu plus parce que on va
payer quoi exercices annales fiches de
cours mais aussi enregistrements sonores
et vidéo
le site est alimenté par les
utilisateurs eux-mêmes et grâce à des
partenariats comme avec le web
pédagogique qui regroupe les blocs de
quatre mille professeurs
ont été nos cours pour avoir une
nouvelle approche de te sujet puis mon
bas si on n'a pas compris on va se
débrouiller tout seul et c'est tellement
d'appeler des amis tard de ça on concède
internet
reste à se prémunir des informations
erronées chez be back des étudiants ou
des enseignants vérifie corrigé complète
les ressources avant toute mise en ligne
une modération indispensable car
l'objectif reste de promouvoir chaque
participation dans sa forme et son
langage propre lycéens en fait faire un
cours de maths ou ou développer un sujet
en philosophie je pense qu'un phénomène
de questions qui peuvent très
intéressant présenté sans savoir
c'est une bonne façon déjà la prendre un
système de vote permet ensuite
d'identifier les meilleures
contributions
avec un million de pages vues chaque
jour be back se rôde encore mais ils
eussent les multiples possibilités
qu'offre internet pour réviser un
réflexe pour ces lycéens de la
génération web
la moitié des foyers français ils ont
aujourd'hui accès